And you can see that the phosphorus has oxidized
in the air and it’s taken some of the paper
with it to generate a nice ‘P’ for phosphorus.
So this is a sample of my favourite element,
this is phosphorus. Phosphorus is a very,
very reactive element, especially this type
of phosphorus which is white phosphorus. Phosphorus
itself, elemental phosphorus, exists as a
number of different allotropes, so a bit like
carbon with diamond and graphite, and here
we have one of these allotropes; it’s white
phosphorus. It exists as discrete molecules
of four phosphorus atoms connected like a
pyramid, and those four phosphorus atoms are
really strained, really reactive and they
want to really react with oxygen as quick
as they can.
This is the sort that is used in phosphorus
bombs. It burns very easily and gives a very
intense white light out of it.
So instantaneously you can see that fantastic
oxidation reaction as the phosphorus reacts
with the molecular oxygen in the gas inside
the flask.
You can put it out quite easily by putting
water on it, provided that it hasn’t got
too hot and the water will just evaporate.
Very reactive form the other allotropes, black
and red phosphorus, are not as reactive and
are much, much easier for us to handle.
Then there’s red phosphorus which is very
much less reactive which is what is used in
matches. It is used to make the heads of so-called
‘non-safety’ matches, which are the ones
you can strike on any sort of material, on
bricks and so on, and they tend to be this
rather red colour here.
So the phosphorus, you’ll notice, that it’s
stored under water, and it’s stored under
water to keep the oxygen and the atmosphere
away because it reacts very vigorously and
can burn, hence the signs, it’s very, very
flammable. It’s so flammable in fact that
it burns just with the heat of the skin. So
you can see a number of scars across my hands,
these are all from playing with phosphorus
and doing reactions and experiments with phosphorus.
Phosphorus is a very important point inside
your body. Some of you may have read Aldous
Huxley’s book called ‘Brave New World’,
which when people died they were sent to the
phosphorus reclamation plant. And each average
size person contains somewhat over a pound
of phosphorus inside their bodies, and nowadays
people can use magnetic resonance imaging
to look and see how the phosphorus is used
inside the body.
So I’ve taken a small sample of my white
phosphorus and I’ve dissolved it in an organic
solvent which is carbon disulphide, because
the P4 is molecular and it dissolves really
quite nicely in this molecular solvent. So
now what we are going to do is we’re going
to go outside and we’re going to put this
on a piece of filter paper and then let the
carbon disulphide evaporate so we can see
the reaction of the phosphorus with the oxygen
and the paper.
And the average person produces inside their
body about 70 kilos a day of a molecule called
ATP, adenosine triphosphate, which is the
energy producing molecule inside the body.
Now you don’t keep 70 kilos inside you,
or you would explode, but you’re using it
up all the time but in the course of the day
you synthesise nearly 70 kilos of this molecule.
So as the carbon disulphide evaporates from
the paper, well there’s a couple of drips.
And you can see that the phosphorus has oxidized
in the air and it’s taken some of the paper
with it to generate a nice ‘P’ for phosphorus.